hey how's it going
good taylor and we have a couple other
people in the room also
i since it's the middle of the day here
i never know how many people
are going to show up we have andre
laurette and taylor
so this is actually going to be um
i somewhat of an informal conversation i
i have some things i want to talk about
uh and i have some things i want you all
to to share as well because we're
dealing with something that is
how can we describe it nobody's ever
experienced before
and so coming up with solutions i think
that
the mind mind hive is a good way
of going about it um i just want to
disable
the um give me one second i want to
disable the
the waiting room so i don't have to let
everybody in
anyway so my name is andrea mia and
i am in portland oregon
i've been a coach for about seven years
now and i come from a very different
background
i worked in the film industry for
17 years or so uh mainly producing but
also
selling films and have worked in
several companies since and and always
been somebody involved with
teaching and trying to help people in
some way
and uh this this uh
time period in covid has been
interesting one
in that i was i had cancer last year
and had treatments up until february
this year
and so just when i was like ready to
come out again
and be like part of the world
um that's when the lockdown happened so
i've been locked down uh since july
of last year really meaning
working from home and not able to have
quote normal life unquote so i've gotten
sort of
used to it in some ways although i don't
know that there's any entire way of
getting used to it
and so i wanted to reveal that about
myself
to you um because that's part of why
i wanted to have this webinar
and have this opportunity for us to
speak
and to talk about
some of the things that are
extraordinary about this time period
and about how we're all figuring out how
to cope
um there's no one prescription for
everybody
in figuring out what this is and what
the new normal might be um
but there are some better ways to do it
and the main thing that
that i want to have for you all and
for myself as well is that we not reach
the point
of burning out of really having
serious stress from from all of it and
uh so that's that's why i wanted to do
this webinar and
um i was going to say you can all unmute
yourselves
if you like because this is going to be
uh
participatory and um
i don't know how to get you all unmuted
i'm just asking you to unmute basically
i think that's the way to do it uh okay
so that's something about me
so today we're going to talk about uh
the different ways that stress is being
manifest in particularly
with regard to work from home and how
work for home
has also changed in and of itself right
now
as well um and
we are also going to talk about ways
that we're all dealing with it
and what strategies that will
hopefully help with stress management so
that we don't reach
the point of of burnout
i will say that one thing to keep in
mind
is that whatever we come up with today
and whatever you might try to bring home
and try differently um
the one thing that i have learned over
time about
stress management that is important
that is that there's never one way about
it necessarily
there can be multiple ways about it
and these can change over time
and part of resilience which is the
um which is strength which is you know
how we are able to bounce
back part of it is is keeping nimble
a little bit with how we're actually
dealing with the stress
what is something new that we might need
to take on to do it differently than we
have before
their challenges of this time period
right now as we know
are different than they were if you were
working from home before just as a
that's what you were doing was working
from home um
the challenges are now that your entire
family is at home for example
and also that the opportunities to go
out and do things
are just different and so the old stress
relievers that we might have had that
were outside of the home
can also not be necessarily available to
us anymore
so it is a different type of time and
uh it's part of why i want to talk about
how to be resilient also by being
flexible
to a good degree so some of the
challenges from the work from home
environment
and these are challenges that uh
we are seeing definitely in the
population that i'm coaching
and also i as as far as all the reading
that i'm doing this seems to be a
consistent
problem that many people are having and
these are not
people necessarily with covid um these
are just
the fact that life
this year as we all know is rather
stressful no matter where you are
in the world it is a different time
so sleep patterns um becoming very
inconsistent
not being able to get enough sleep or
getting too much sleep
um either of those could be signs of
uh stress eating overeating or
undernourishing yourself eating too much
emotional eating this year
these are other signs that we are
um not necessarily as calm as we
could be um too much or too little
company i think this is actually one of
the hugest things
um i know that and and i will be
personal about
about this i lived in a uh
studio apartment with my boyfriend
for a over through the whole cancer
thing
and into this and
it was too much too much time together
24 hours a day all the time
without a break both working from home
a lot of families are experiencing that
with children around as well
no break from each other and
the other side of it are people that
are at home and by themselves
and not able to have company
they may be working from home but they
have no
human contact that isn't in this fashion
perhaps in
zoom or in very limited basis
and we are animals and we often like
to have human contact and
that's why it's very hard to for example
find a dog now if you go to the pound if
you go to
places where you adopt dogs most dogs
have been adopted actually since the
lockdown started because
people crave you know other animals to
be around on some level
if not humans than other animals that
that are out there
and um if you don't have that
that can become a stressor if it's not
if it's not
available to you lack of structure
is probably one of the more obvious ones
i would say
um in the sense of if you're and this
one is an interesting one because
one of the biggest complaints that we
are hearing about people from people
excuse me is not having any
um difference between my work time
and my play time or my not work time
and the work time creeping more and more
into the
regular lifetime so that there's no
difference between the two and that work
has become less efficient in the sense
of
okay i used to go to work and it was
from you know
eight o'clock to four o'clock and in
that and when i went home it was over
right now it may be eight o'clock to
well i was still working on stuff at
like ten o'clock at night
you know yes i took breaks and i did
other things but it's like it's just
a big creep that goes on
um when you have a lack of structure and
a lack of definition and boundaries
um and so that seems to be a very
consistent problem is that people are
actually and you know you you might
think that people are working less
because they're working from home
however what seems to be happening is
that people are actually working to some
degree
more meaning that they're spending more
attention
on working from home
another problem is and these are a
little different from each other a
little the same too many distractions or
lack of focus
um obviously the distractions are
different if you have a whole family at
home
and that you're taking care of a family
and
children have needs and they're going to
school
from the house and that can bring out a
whole lot of different things that are
distractions in the sense but also
working from home and not having
designated areas for example for all the
different activities that you're doing
and
looking at it as if well i'm working
from home and that means
i work in this space that i'm in right
here
as opposed to i work in
the entire space of my apartment
i could work anywhere there's a freedom
in that but
in a way there's so many more
distractions and it
leads to a lack of focus to some degree
because
well if i work in my kitchen i can
possibly cook at the same time that i'm
working
or if i work in my bedroom well i can
possibly lie down
while i'm working oh and if i work on
the couch
my gosh well that's where the tv is
maybe i want to turn that on
or by the books over there that's
another whole area i could possibly want
to
be distracted by so you know some of
this
is that if you're surrounded by your
every every thing that you love to do
your home and your surroundings things
that that you like
and love um they can
pull you away from your focus
all we have is the attention that we put
on things
and uh that's what time is basically
and when your attention is pulled into a
lot of different directions at the same
time
it's hard to make your time valuable
in that way and that can also be a
stressor
so i lorette satish and taylor
thank you for joining i wanted to know
uh
from you all what are you experiencing
as far as stressors go um
what are you finding that has been
different since march or february i'm
not sure when
all of you might have entered this zone
um some places are are faster than
others but i my question is
when have you experienced stress
and how has it been manifesting itself
and please unmute yourselves
yeah i can uh go first um so
literally everything on the slide
well i i don't really like sleeping so
sleep is always
the first thing that i you know
sacrifice if i want to
get my work done or have more time to
play or
what have you and then um i've
just been free to get as many snacks as
i want now
um so i've definitely been eating a lot
more um
and not nearly as healthy um
and then um the structure is completely
gone out the window
oh yeah and uh being
a software engineer like i have free
free range of the internet so all of
all of the distractions and lack of
focus so
everything all at the same time so i
have a question for you
what have you what has have you tried to
adjust
anything to make it work better for you
yet
um yes uh it kind of ebbs and flows
depending on what i'm trying to
prioritize so like i
started doing a sleep schedule um
and then like had a routine of like i'd
do some mindfulness before going to bed
had like a pre-bed routine like
doing reflecting on the day and then my
mindfulness stuff and then
going to sleep and it's all at a
scheduled time each day of the week
but then things started to ramp up with
work school so
like uh i'll worry about sleep later
and then with like eating i've been
trying to do
more healthy stuff so going to the
farmer's market and things like that but
then
also was like stressed and so like ah i
want to treat myself and stuff
it's the new thing yeah yeah
yeah that's a hard word how did how do
you
um since you've been working at home
how long have you been working at home
um for
about two months so i'm i'm a grad
student but i'm
doing remote uh school so i'm used to
being
at home but now i'm like working and so
you're doing everything now yeah
yeah yeah which is different do you have
like a designated area for your work
no so i'm actually away from home i
relocated for work and so
uh this yeah i usually i just work in my
room
my bedroom in your bedroom do you have
choices
in the house of where to work uh i'm in
like a dorm kind of setup
so there's like this office space but
i'm trying to
keep to myself right okay
um do you have any because this is
this is uh there are things called
screens that are wonderful
um for breaking up space in a in a room
even if you're just in a studio uh
but even in a very
place uh figuring out ways to designate
like this is separate this is this
is where i work and this is where i
sleep
and trying to get to the point where you
don't have to see your bed
when you're working and you don't have
to see your desk
figuring out how to break that up a
little bit
that's one thing that that i found um
has helped me a lot living in a studio
apartment
and i've used a screen to block it off
so that i'm not tempted to go work from
bed for example
uh or uh which is quite easy
um but the it's almost like it it's
poisoning the area basically
and so that's one thing i've tried in
that way what if you try
to so i love that you're doing the
mindfulness
to go to sleep um and and
to have a bit of a ritual although you
were saying that it was also sort of
deteriorating
as you got more work for sure yeah
so how can you bring that back again
um yeah i just need to be more
disciplined in my
in my schedule um i've i've
thrown it out the window so i could i
should just bring that
real debt back in and be more
disciplined
with that what's one thing nice about it
i must say that when you mentioned it it
came to mind that
one of the things i've lost track of is
time
is today monday it's like it's tuesday
wait no it's monday it's
i remember something was different on
sunday
and um that that that has been the case
now for months
i've had that feeling right you'll have
to figure out
is it wednesday or what day is this and
how am i gonna mark time um and we need
somehow we're
we're we're creatures that need that we
need to
be able to mark time in some way to know
that it is past
and to have a sense of ourselves within
it
and um so ritual wise
like you you you just mentioned i
started creating rituals at night
also like registering
reading you know before i go to sleep at
night and
registering like what the day was and
that it was
whatever sunday and and uh
what was my life like on sunday what did
i get to do that was extraordinary or
fun or
nice in some way so i'm not even
terribly deeply mindful
just registering the time
and where i am in my week and what are
my intentions for the week
and that i do on sunday but but during
the week also just reminding myself of
like what else i want to accomplish that
week
before i go to sleep um that's one thing
i do with
to help them lorette raj
yeah i'd like to go next um yeah
talking about sleep cycle it's almost 4
am here on tuesday
i see the problem satish already
i mean this is nothing okay this is
nothing because today i just kept alarm
and
specifically for this webinar i kind of
caught up well
and yeah i do have a separate room
table and uh was able to designate some
region apart
but one thing i mean apart from most of
the other patterns which you already
covered for
taylor uh one thing i personally face
is too much time with family members and
especially and especially if these
people are just
toxic like they're having fights between
each other like
you have to stop work just to have just
to handle your parents fighting or
just to have such scenarios is like
something i'm not able to cope up with
like
so do you have private space
yes i do okay but it's loud enough you
hear it
yep yeah that's really tough i just
spent a month at home
uh with my mother and brother and they
weren't loud in fact they were very
quiet
um but they
annoyed the hell out of me every now and
then while i was working
and i was suddenly grateful not to have
to be
around people i can relate to that
that that that can be really challenging
so uh
so what do you think you need
to do to have
the space and i mean don't mean just
physical space i also mean mental space
spares you hearing them
or having to engage with them it in such
a
constant way
i totally don't have a optimal solution
for that as of now but
uh i i also think that the
this particular situation has put them
also in stress and
they need some ways of
adapting to it is one thing i would
definitely
go for is like having a word with them
or maybe
engaging in a conversation with them
thinking about um thinking about
changing how he's like going away all of
you even
to to get a different perspective
whether it's going
hiking or going and renting a little
place by the beach
or you know something i'm saying is
something unsafe but i am
saying something safe but shake it up
to shake up what it's like to be around
each other
and what it's like to be
i if they're caught in a rut too
and are getting to the point where they
can't stand being around each other or
just
stressed about it sometimes changing the
situation for everybody
can breathe new life into
a new life into us basically
do you think that's possible are you
like oh my god no
more time that would be the worst
reaction i'm on either side i mean like
it's
good to try something that might work
but
at the same time yes i mean will it work
or not i'm still skeptical about
it but yes i would definitely give it a
go yeah it's
it's something to maybe see how it is
because
they're also
you know they're saying that that the
divorce rates
are going really up um
all over the place in the world because
people are suddenly
stuck with each other all the time and
they're they're like
all those things that i didn't find um
i found acceptable in small doses from
you now i'm getting in large doses and i
can't escape them
and for people to remember what it is
they liked about each other
and to be in a different environment
um and shake themselves out of the
environment they're in
that can be a way to just
like exercising you know like getting
the the blood going to the brain
all new experiences new new environments
also gets that blood going to the brain
and gets us thinking
oh like this is something different oh i
can learn now
like something entirely different what
it is to be crunching in the
in the uh the leaves i forgot what that
is like i only
you know it was last fall that i got to
do that i need to go out and feel that
again um anyway that's just
just an idea of uh
maybe a way to shake up the triangle
i think it's three of you is that right
yep and a brother who occasionally
visits but
that's that's separate thing again yeah
you're the brother who's now there all
the time
yes right okay so
um you know and that's it that's a
that's a tough responsibility in some
ways when you also see
that things may be deteriorating in a
family around you
and that you're kind of powerless to do
much about it so
um proposing something to
make people feel differently and come
together in a different way
um maybe
yeah thank you you're welcome of course
of course
anna would you like to share how you are
doing during this uh
during this situation
or raj sure
i'll go ahead okay great well
yeah things have been little different
uh for the last few months but uh
you know i try to uh
put myself in a position where i can
focus
and first thing that changed is i
changed my iphone to blackberry and that
changed everything
how did that change everything i mean i
i looked at my screen time and i looked
at uh
where i'm spending most of my time so it
looks like social media is killing time
so
yeah i wanted to transition myself so i
can work better and utilize the time
so first thing i did is change my phone
and
got a blackberry where i still have
internet and everything but i can't
scroll through because i don't have
touch anymore
right so all the fun things are gone
well i i set up some time because i
didn't throw away my iphone because you
know it's very hot so
yeah i just set a schedule like so i did
few transitions over the last few months
and then i
set up a pattern now it's really helping
me
get back onto my routine now that we are
working from home
yeah that's the first thing that changed
because every morning the moment
i get up i used to spend hours of time
on my phone
so getting a blackberry i mean
getting a phone without a touch changed
it because it's hard to scroll through
and open up so
i think that's the first thing that
helped me uh realize how much time i'm
wasting
and then i and then what i did is like
um
i switched uh using tick tock
going back to audible so so whenever i
want to open
tick tock so i i open audible now
so to listen to a book or you know read
something on audible so that uh
that is getting that is making me get uh
used to a new habit
yeah and then so i was browsing through
on uh
how to you know focus more on
you know your work and everything and
then i understood that working out is
also better
so i ordered a boxing bag so everyone
i just spent five minutes on that so
that really
is helping me i mean this hasn't uh
going on for the last
month and uh month by month i analyzed
where i'm wasting my time and then three
things that are helping me over the last
one or two weeks
is like changing my phone and uh
you know refreshing myself every one or
because uh
what was happening earlier is like you
work for like 30 minutes 40 minutes you
feel like oh
i've worked so much i need to go look at
social media youtube or something
yeah which i am now spending it on
hitting the boxing bag or you know
lifting some weights at home so
well what i love i love what you're
doing is this natural thing that
um by the way that could be your reward
is looking at social media but limiting
and saying hey i have five minutes
before i go back to work again
that can be your reward even though i
love that you're beating something up
for your reward because
yeah yeah definitely and that is where
i'm missing it up because like now i set
the schedule like every night
one hour before i go to bed i use social
media and that is dragging me till like
1am in the morning so that is something
that i need to get rid of
right so maybe maybe it's putting it in
differently i
i was i was saying that the um the
pomodoro method of
managing your time is is basically
structured on
you know creating 25 minutes blocks
and then giving yourself a five minute
reward at the end of it and you work
towards the reward
and oftentimes people i talk to that
is playing on social media but
they're only given five minutes to do it
and then they have to go back to their
task and maybe
maybe moving your social media
throughout the day but in
small amounts as opposed to the endless
you know the endless play in the middle
of the night
um maybe that would that maybe that
would be a way to manage that a little
bit better
yeah yeah but it was i mean it's
uh for me i don't know about everybody
but it's very hard to go back
and like social media is meant for that
right once you dig in you it's very hard
to go back
so that five minutes away drag you into
five hours as well so that is the
problem for me so
yes so either setting a timer
so at least you know when you've blown
it you know
like so it doesn't you know that it's
like okay i'm giving myself five minutes
i'm giving myself 10 minutes that's
that's all it is and then i really need
to put it down but but you're right you
know to some degree it's an addiction
thing
and and so once you pick it up it's
really hard to put down
and um so
there yeah i don't know that's
interesting i think that they also say
the whole thing about
you know not looking at the screens
before you go to sleep at night
literally because of the light that that
is part of what keeps us up
and that's a self-fulfilling prophecy if
you start looking at it and it's keeping
you up and you're looking at it and it's
keeping you up and
and um so it's not a great thing to do
as i'm sure we all know
uh to have these things by our beds and
to
bring them into the bed everybody says
that that's like
the worst thing to do imaginable right
um
but it definitely messes with your sleep
patterns also
so finding a different time to do it raj
if if you want to spend you know a
couple hours a day on social media
maybe it needs to be in the middle of
the day and just say
fine that's what it is that's when i'm
doing it but nighttime i can't do it
yeah definitely yeah i think i think
that's what i think i
i i think the ultimate solution is just
to get rid of the phone so
that's what i figured in my case so i'm
gonna do it but it's
hard to throw it away at right at a a
day because the next time you're gonna
get it you're never gonna throw it so i
just wanna do it in a slow and
what about wait a second without
throwing out the phone necessarily
before going that drastic um what about
just removing the apps well
you you have already registered it via
email right so you get notifications on
your email that makes you curious to
click on it and download the app so yeah
that's true that's true well well it's i
mean it's not about
like spending too much time on social
media is wasted i mean we see a lot of
content which may be for you to smile or
you to learn something new
but yeah that one piece of controlling
it of how you use it is where
i have problems i don't know about
others but yeah it's it's supposed to
love to hear from others because i have
problems with it myself
so i get it i i just and
i uh i think one of the other problems
with it
is where are you living raj
um i i was in portland oregon but uh
right now i'm in omaha nebraska oh my
okay
so you know at least in the united
states obviously
not everybody's probably from the us but
it's inundating
the the news is endless and
mostly negative and stressful and
unavoidable if you turn on any
anything and so you'll appreciate raj i
live downtown portland
my distractions have been protests you
know
for the last i don't know three four six
months yeah that's when i moved away
from portland
time i can't tell anymore
so they're quieter now definitely
but it's made it uh become like a
not quite a war zone but just really
unpleasant outside
and um so going out has become
challenging
where i live as well uh
so anyway i i love your idea of get a
blackberry to
like get rid of part of the problem
because nobody wants to go back to nokia
anymore so
yeah yeah at least i have it
at least i can say i have a smartphone
so
i i must say we've all existed you know
as humans we've existed for
what ten thousand more than ten thousand
years
civilization without these things
and and we had lives and uh
now it feels like uh become reliant on
these things
for our our lives and
well it's not true yeah that's what i
realized so it's like i was under the
impression that
we got addicted but i looked at the
documentary
netflix called social media yeah and
that if you
if you look at that that will show us we
didn't get addicted they made us get
addicted so oh yeah
oh yeah that's how they get their money
and why we need
new ones every two years they also make
them
you know every year every year and it's
already sold out the new version is
already sold out
without a without a charger and a
headset so
yeah this is this is painful stuff okay
thank you i think you had some really
good ideas
on on how to deal thank you for sharing
um lemai or ron or
um satish if you'd like to share please
just unmute yourself
and um what we're sharing right now
is ways that we've learned how to adapt
to um to what's going on
actually i'm going to switch to one of
my other slides
because i wanted to to bring this up
um there was a study that was done
of 35
high-level care executives
and they were testing them as to they're
all
high stress level people we're talking
about people that are running hospitals
all over the world and um
the issue of whether they were stressed
is a non-issue they were stressed
absolutely but whether they hit burnout
or not
um that that's actually the thing that
we're all
sort of trying not to do right is
burnout
and there was a lot of things that they
did in order to avoid it and a lot of it
had to do with whether they invested
time in themselves or not
whether they spent time exercising
and being with themselves or
they just kept plowing through things
and so it it may turn into different
things for you how you invest in
yourself
but that seems to be one of the key
factors in
not getting to the point where you are
you actually need help
um from others in a more structured way
or
that you are really just at the your
wits end
of whatever we want to call it um
some things to pay attention to here and
these are signs that
you're heading towards burnout as
opposed to just you're having stress
and trying to feel with how to deal with
the stress and that's
that you're tr you're starting to do a
lot of negative talk
about other people about yourself about
everything
that it seems to be that your way of
looking at the world at this point has
is taking a turn towards negativity
that's something we have to pay
attention to and listen for in ourselves
is this is the world totally crap and
everything is awful about it
uh every single thing you run into or is
this your perspective now
and if this is becoming your specific
perspective
that could be a sign that you're heading
towards burnout
things that you've done in the past that
to make yourself resilient
are not working anymore they are
feeling like they're too difficult to do
it's too difficult to go to sleep
on time at night it's too difficult to
eat healthy because
pizza is so much easier um it's
too difficult to talk to friends because
well
i don't know then i have to like go on
zoom or i have to go on the phone and
just you start to get
like things are just too difficult to do
things that would have made you feel
good in the past
that's that's when you can start to tell
that your resilience might be flagging
and another thing work-wise um
especially
is when you notice that you're making
mistakes
that things are happening that you would
have never made that sort of mistake
before
but now you're like wait a second what a
mess that is
i i just i noticed it but maybe i
stopped it but
it was a mistake if you find yourself
having more and more of those
that's also a sign that you are that
your resilience is flagging basically
and that you that you're heading towards
burnout which is what we don't want
of course um things about burnout though
and and stress that we have to
acknowledge and
and it's it's kind of interesting that
one of the things that has changed also
during lockdown
is that uh so much of the mental health
help that we have first of all we're
realizing that
there's not enough mental health for
everybody um
and it is it is difficult to get it
that's for sure
however it's all gone online so
i what's good about that is it has
brought down a lot of the barriers
especially for men
going to seek mental health um help if
you know somebody to talk to
somebody to help share wisdom with um
that's become a little easier and
uh for people because it is online even
though it's hard to find people that
maybe you relate to
and what we are seeing is that um
more men are seeking out help now that
they don't have to walk into an office
um that's a good thing you know that uh
because there's no shame in seeking help
um
about things or seeking different
perspectives
or in you know having the ability to
invest in yourself that way also to have
someone to speak to whether it be your
priest rabbi chief
psychiatrist psychologist whatever
having being able to invest
in yourself and being able to talk
things through
and and have some time that's just
just for you really um that can be
something
that uh is important
and the other thing is you know i was
writing down identifying the type of
help you need
um sometimes so it's one thing to know
that
i need help this is this is it's too
hard i'm
i'm getting stressed out i don't know
where to go
and it's another thing knowing what the
right help is going to be
and um
that's not for me to say but when i what
i am going to say is that
there can be different help at different
times that
um and you need to be open to
looking for it and finding it and
and listening to it once you do find it
so
it may be that you you know a trusted
friend
is actually the help that you need and
being able to talk to them is sufficient
but then you have to you know invest in
talking to that friend
and making that a reality or maybe it's
somebody who is
has professional experience and is able
to sit back and and talk about family
relationships
and dynamics and and have different
perspective on like how to deal with the
dynamics or how the dynamics need to
change
and a friend may not be the appropriate
person for that because you need someone
who has more
serious experience or longer time than
study
into methodology that might be helpful
and so try to assess where the stresses
really are and what kind of help you
really
need when it is beyond
your family and friends and when it is
something that
you know something to have a
professional perspective on this
might be interesting or to have a
religious perspective on this
might be interesting to me um
and it can also not be work in which
case
fine you can go somewhere else you know
to find the
to find help it doesn't have to be a
one-shot deal
and so that's what i mean by
experimentation
that since there is no one answer
for everyone's issues
and problems and and stresses
i cultivating that sense of curiosity
and willingness to experiment
with yourselves on yourselves um
i think is a very healthy thing to do
and to open
yourself up to it um and
i just to give you an example i um
i went to north carolina for a month
and visited a friend in the uh
in the mountains of north carolina and
her new boyfriend
um is the head of the astronomy club for
western north carolina which is a big
club it turns out
and we went out and we looked at the
stars and not only did we look at the
stars we were able to see
uh jupiter and all of its
four of its moons excuse me and we were
able to see saturn in its
and its um rings and in between the
rings and stuff
just with this telescope on this
mountain
i haven't looked through a telescope
since i was probably 10 years old or
something
and it inspired me to go wait a second
what a wonderful thing to do
during lockdown going out and like
just being with the universe and
seeing these beautiful things that are
around us
and so i joined the astronomy club when
i came back here
um which does me regularly so i don't
have to buy a
whatever you know telescope but i can
participate in this and go out
and um and think about things that are
bigger than me
and so what i
why i bring that up is that that it was
an experiment
it was an experiment that paid off
because it gave me something
that i i wasn't focused on before and i
don't think that
without lockdown i would have first of
all
probably gone and visited in that way
and second of all
um that that was
like one of the few options of things
that we could all do together was to go
out and do that outside
so um i want to encourage
experimentation
as well and ultimately what we're all
doing right now
is we're living a lot more consciously
with the fact that things are uncertain
we can't make the plans that we've
wanted to make before
or we've made in the past we can't make
the same plans right now
and things will be different but they
won't be the same
and living with that type of uncertainty
is a stressor in and of itself we're
creatures of habit
as as raj was talking about very much
and i
not knowing where things are going or
not having a clear sense of where things
are going can be
a real stressor the nice thing is yeah
all of us have the problem
all of us have the same uncertainty and
maybe we always have
the same uncertainty um we're just
becoming a little more conscious about
it right now
so the only thing i would also say is
that you know we're in it together
and um and that's why i wanted this to
be an open conversation actually
because there's no reason that that
ron and laurette don't have
some of the answers that raj and me
need to hear that might make a
difference
to how we're dealing with stress and
might give us permission to experiment
and to try things that might uh
make this a healthier time for ourselves
so these are just uh things
things to keep in mind that uh we can
talk about that are
things that can keep the stress levels
down uh animals
having animals in your life exercise
spelled wrong i think
uh hobbies uh like my astronomy thing
goals and structures and also one of the
biggest ones i think is adjusting your
expectations
of um i think when when
the lockdown started there's
some people that decided oh great this
is my time to master a language and take
a painting
and i'm going to write that book and i'm
going to take three courses and i'm
going
because you know i'm trapped here so i
might as well do all of these things
because all i have is time right
and we saw a lot of people
start burning out from that start
burning out from
putting their expectations and demands
on their lives
to such a high degree that they didn't
acknowledge that
okay this is also an extraordinary time
and i also need to just take care of
myself
and i also need to get through it i
don't need to
win i don't need to beat it
um but i do need to get through it
and that winning and beating it on
expectation of what
you went into this with and what what is
happening now
for you and what will maybe continue
happening for the next you know months
to year
i don't know um
is being loving with yourself
about the expectations that you're
putting on yourself
as to what you want to achieve and what
you want
what you are capable of doing if you
come from a place of love
yourself and to others as opposed to
high expectations and demands
um and
[Music]
just sort of intolerance
for imperfection um
those are those are ways to get yourself
even more stressed basically
so i encourage you to to find a place of
love for yourself
and those around you and to come at it
from that
point of view rather than having great
expectations of
of how we're all going to be just
fabulous
during this and after this
um would anybody else like to complete
and please
do um share either
things that they have done to make this
a
less stressful situation for themselves
because we all have things to learn from
each other or
things that that are bothering them that
they would like to
you know share and and see if we have
any ideas
as to what might make it better go ahead
hello andrea and hello everyone thank
you for this lovely session
i like it so much and yeah sure
with the lockdown we were at home and we
want to
improve and learn more i've been in
udacity scholarships and you coursera
also etc
but what i want to share is my stress
i have been learning machine learning
for one year
right now and every time i've been
contacted by
someone who want me to work with him for
as freelancer or in company i feel i'm
stressed
i feel i'm not ready yet i feel that i
cannot do it
sometimes i neglect just i don't answer
the the message and i feel like no i
if i say yes i will not do it and
i will just have a bad reputation so i
don't know what to do
with this feeling because i feel that
block me i did a lot of personal
projects
i write blogs in medium some students
contact me to help them i help them with
their projects
but when it is about me or someone for
money i feel like no i cannot do it
i don't know what to do i have a
question for you
would you hire you to do a project
uh yes
i think i can do it i can i can do it
uh even if i i can if the project is new
i will search and i will not let it down
but i don't trust myself i think that
much
but you would hire yourself yes
okay so you don't totally not believe in
yourself actually
you do believe in yourself to the degree
that you know that you do a good job
but what sort of that input have you
gotten from others
when you have done work for them uh they
are happy
and they thank me and sometimes they
come back for another
consulting okay so
you would hire you and people who have
hired you would hire you
these other people though these other
people that are
that are coming at you why why do you
want to
not give them the benefit of your
service
uh because all of the other people it
was volunteering
it was just doing it as a volunteer not
not a work not paying not paying so it's
the actually like going
it the pay thing that yeah
of oh they actually want to give me
money and now that's a different thing
than what i was doing before right
yeah yeah it's not different
by the way it is it isn't it
isn't a work whether it's paid or not
paid
how you show up is what really matters
um you could have been doing terrible
work even though you were unpaid for it
it could have been terrible yeah and
maybe you wouldn't have invested in it
nicely because it was unpaid work also
but i think that that that that issue
of being that little line which is not a
big line because
um money is not so important to
many people as it is that we make it
into such a big thing and so
important um it's their way of saying
uh i'm gonna give you money because
that's what i have to give you
could you please solve a problem for me
if you feel like you could solve a
problem for them
that is their only way of saying thank
you
yeah giving you money
so if you think you can solve the
problem for them
you need to solve the problem for them
it's
wonderful right that's that's why they
want to give you money yeah
that's all work is is just
people having problems and other people
and and then deciding to give other
people money to solve their problems
so you sound like you're able to solve
people's problems and that you have been
doing this
yeah and these new people
that's their only thank you
and it's kind of faulting not to take it
their thank you from them
yeah yeah right yeah if we want to think
like this yeah
because uh i was thinking like just
go ahead and send your resume if they
say no
or they don't like your job what's the
best thing that
or the worst thing is could happen they
are
going to say no and it's that's it but i
think the idea is
in my head but when i want to do it i
felt like
no i cannot i don't know i had those
ideas in my head but
when it is for action something kept me
so how can you do it differently how can
you respond differently to people
um when they are asking you to help them
solve a problem
um i think it's just first time if i can
send my resume for one and i do it for
the first time i think uh all the steps
are going to be easier
even with machine learning when i wanted
to start the first time i still
that i cannot do it so you need to get
over that hump
basically just yeah have the first one
happen and then
and then get used to it on some level so
so how how
so are you going to say yes to the next
one
i want that yeah badly
is there anything that can stop that
would stop you from saying yes right now
no oh okay
good so the answer will be yes
i would love for you to write me and
tell me
when you say yes okay okay okay
as i would like to know when when that
happens
and how that happens and i'm just going
to put um and this is for all of you
that's fine
uh in the chat oh i say that i'm trying
to put it in the chat but i there i am
uh this is my email address
[Music]
oh sorry go ahead taylor yeah um i was
just gonna say this this
uh sounds like um you're dealing with
impostor syndrome which is like
i think super common uh in the computing
field
um one thing that i've done is like
writing myself a little pep talk type
things
uh so i'll like leave myself notes um
just notes of encouragement and things
like that to
kind of remind myself that i am good
enough even though
sometimes i might disagree with that or
feel like
um otherwise in comparison to other
people in the field and things like that
so
it might be helpful to like leave
notes um for yourself or like
reminders to like do something um
things in places where you'll see them
you know frequently
that's a lovely idea yeah i also would
like to add one point
so i have been in a similar scenario a
long time before so my solution would be
to
uh i know you're having a hard time
accepting a project
because you know your reputation may go
bad but uh
you know if you're gonna stay in the
same way you're gonna always stay in the
same way
one thing is just talk to your client
and tell set the expectations that this
is your first project it may be delayed
or whatever the reason so they are not
surprised
and second thing is to go ahead and do
it because you know
even if you fail nothing is going to go
bad for you because
you will learn a lot of lessons which
will even make you grow faster than you
expect
because if you keep rejecting all those
offers you're always going to be
rejected you're never going to accept
anything
so the first project is always the key
no matter the outcome of it
it's about you getting confident enough
this will also improve you uh as a
person
so that way you you can communicate
better with your client
i mean the whole point again to sum it
up is to
uh just go out and give it a try even if
it fails you learn
lesson if it gets succeeded then you
know your confidence even grows up
and just to add a tip to that
try uh meeting up with other
professionals in your similar area like
there are so many machine learning
communities
just join them and you know get
suggestions when you're struck in the
project or something so that way they
can also help you
bring up your confidence yeah that's it
thank you thank you
thank you hive brain everybody that was
wonderful
um wonderful you're sharing would
anybody else like to share before we
we lock down for the day
um yeah i just like to let you all know
there's a book
that kind of talks about all this that's
relatively new called indestructible
i don't know i joined late i don't know
if you mentioned it or not
but um it's also it's written by the guy
who actually wrote
the book um called hook that
teaches companies how to get people um
to use their
applications over and over again to get
hooked on their applications
and in this book industry he teaches
people
how to not be distracted
and to focus on your work and one of the
main takeaways is time blocking
which you can you look that up as well
but
yeah indestructible is a really good
resource so i can post a little
yeah i was going to say if you could put
it into the chat
that would be great as a resource to
share for people
let's see where the chat is there's the
shop
um indistractable is what it's called
yeah yeah i've got i've got it pulled up
on
amazon let me just copy this link
i think hooker itself is a better book
first to start off with
which one the hooked the same author oh
hooked
yeah i don't think you need to you
definitely do not need to read hooked
before you i would actually recommend
reading indistractible first
if you haven't read either one of them
okay
wonderful because it's more pertinent to
this topic
yeah but definitely they're both great
books for sure hooked is more about how
to
get people hooked but it it's it's
it's good for um you know knowing the
mechanics of causing you to
to be um you know
i guess be hooked for lots of better
words yeah to be hooked yeah
they're good titles actually um
so and they it sounds like they rely
what's what's inside so
thank you for sharing that ron i
appreciate that
so it does anybody else have anything to
share if not we'll be
we'll be wrapping up
thank you very much for joining and
thank you i
i really appreciate um people opening up
about this
i i don't know one person at
all who hasn't been affected by um
the situation that we're all in and
hasn't
had to develop new uh new types of
resilience
to deal with it and so i'm just grateful
to you all
that you've shared and that you've given
me the opportunity to share as well
and i encourage you to keep
experimenting
and keep trying to find ways that
keep you not burning out
basically and maybe still stress but
able to manage it
and um and able to find joy in this time
as well
thank you and i will see you all around
the udacity
campus as they say okay take care
bye-bye
thanks see ya thank you
you're welcome